so with your pen in hand I want you to
have a look at this from just the
informations on the table what would you
guess this table is asking you to do
what's going on yes Hannah yeah very
good and we've got the multiply and QR
PR and there's one other thing had I not
giving you a heading that would tell you
that can you have a look at some years
okay fantastic so you can see right up
there in the top left-hand corner so
really what this is is x tangles keep
times tables now what I'd like you do
with me for this first side it's been
nice and simple and have a look and say
what does this um this top rectangle in
here what's it going to have internet
don't just tell me the answer tell me
how I get the answer someone tell me
what to write yeah okay I'm gonna go
three times so you can all do this with
me 3 times 0 & 3 lots of three groups of
0 of course is 0 fantastic okay in fact
once we filled that in we know from one
of our early early number facts that
anything times zero is going to be 0
right so everything in this column here
I'm going to have 2 times 0 or so 0 yeah
1 times 0 still 0 and you better believe
that zero times zero is zero at least I
hope so okay you've got no lot of
nothing so you have a whole lot of
nothing okay so you can see here if I
went out to go over to the right here I
can continue this pattern the patterns
what I'm after okay three times one is
three three times two is three sorry 1 x
2 sorry sweeties 21 times one and the
last one time zero is still zero okay
dusty you give a question man
ah so you're asking about my order are
you yes I have a very very important
reason for why my numbers are in the
order that they are suffice to say i can
multiply any numbers I like like I could
have made this 304 if I wanted to and
just worked out my 304 times tables if I
really wanted to I don't today but
you'll see why when we have a look at
the other side why the numbers are in
that order okay we're done half a table
can you go ahead and fill out the rest
of the day we won't take you long we're
only going up to three go ahead and put
those numbers in okay there's simple
simple products all right things are
looking fantastic okay now what I'd like
you to notice before we move on and turn
it on okay is just have a look at how
many patterns their art in this table
okay for instance if we just have a look
at say our this diagonal up here you see
this diagonal that's it love is in a day
and will be a special moment those
numbers are about yeah it went numb
there's square numbers out there 0 x 0 y
1 x 1 1 to x 2 3 x 3 and I can keep
going if I have more song right there
are lots of other pansy can see symmetry
you can see nine numbers climbing up
don't miss Clemmie death okay right now
pause for a second so far what we've
done here is what you know if since like
well when did you first learn
multiplication firstly excited you want
you to I'd say so you've known this for
a long time okay but what we've just
been looking at which is new is integers
and what do integers add to this or
integers out not just these positive
numbers what are the numbers am I going
to add in to hear ya I'm gonna have
negatives too okay turn out of place
ok now we're not going to do all of them
working for this all because I think
you'll be able to notice a lot of these
are fairly straightforward out and get
the idea be fair in fact a whole quarter
of this table you have already done
which fought i have already don't look
carefully yes round okay we've done the
end help me at the top right you can see
these are the 0 1 2 3 and the three to
10 we had before so we just start with
me just by copying the numbers you
already know just we have the zeros and
the positives you don't need to do the
whole working the three times three is
this just give me the numbers okay you
can see I'm up to date with you guys as
well now here's where the patterns
really become interesting okay I want
you to have a look at sea I've got four
columns that I filled in one two three
four I want to look at the second column
the one second from the left can you see
down here as I climb down from the top
to the bottom as I go in descending
order you can see is a very obvious
pattern right how do I get from one
number climbing down to the next what am
i doing what's the difference yeah i am
i'm subtracting one every time do you
see that so in fact if you could write
with me i'm subtracting one tier 4 3 2 2
i'm subtracting one again to go from 2
to 1 and so on okay now being in that
pattern continues you can kind of
predict what's going to happen to the
bottom of the table right if i'm
subtracting one every time right then I
should keep subtracting one there's no
reason why the pattern should change
right so what's the next number
underneath that 0 yes it's negative 1
right 0 take away 1 0 minus 1 is
negative 1 when i subtract one again i'm
going to get now you have two and then
i'm going to get great so you can see
the pattern right again you don't
necessarily have to write this on yours
cuz it's going to get pretty crowded if
I have a look at this pattern here in
the next column over you can tell me
what am i doing to climb down the ladder
yeah I'm taking away to write every
single time so we can continue this
pattern down here where I don't know the
numbers I'm
keep on subtracting two subtracting
tunes and then you don't need me to tell
you what's government forget to happen
on this last call what's going to happen
here i'm going to subtract it okay let's
fill that ass bottom round corner now
before we move on just have a look all
the established right we started with
this we started with on your reverse
side just looking at the positives and
including the zeros okay only know
exactly time is bad but when we have a
look at negatives if you have a positive
number like say two and you multiply it
by a negative likes a negative two right
two times nature is going to give you
another negative number back and I can
do this for all of these they're all
giving you a negative numbers okay all
these products in his corner where else
can i see a pan-pan I could continue
there's loads of them we want to suggest
you can see what here doesn't
yeah you're talking about these ones in
here yeah very good so you can see I've
got loads of spots where this zero time
something so you return something and we
know all of those let's fill them in
hell all those are going to be zero ok
now I'm going to show you one more
pattern and then we're going to throw
the rest the table you notice here I was
climbing down a ladder right I was going
from the top to the bottom I've got the
whole left-hand side of the table that I
haven't filled in so I kind of want to
see what happens when I go from right to
left does that make sense let's just do
the first round when I go from right to
left which is another color let's go
pick from right to left right to left
right to left what is happening each
time what operation am i doing yet yeah
it's getting smaller and smaller by
three every time till you notice that so
let's write in there it's take away
three then take away three again and
take away three one more time so being
that's the pattern all the way from the
right-hand corner up into the middle
there's no reason to think that the
pattern won't continue right so let's
pop those arrows over here and I'm going
to be taking away three in this top row
taking away three every single time now
we just like we saw in the review
questions we're really good at doing all
of these operations was just adding and
subtracting so what am I going to have
what numbers will i have in my top
drawer yeah go ahead
next so from here yeah negative nine
then yeah very good and you can see it
fits that pink pattern that we just put
in there ok so again just like top to
bottom we're getting smaller and smaller
right to left we're also doing that and
you can fill in the rest of the table
just watch out when you get in the
bottom left for give it a shot and then
I'll come around to have a look what
you're doing